(suspenseful music)
- I am a comedian.
- I'm a comedian.
- And I'm a comedian.
(suspenseful music)
- Hello, everyone.
- So where did everybody
come from? Everybody from LA?
- Sacramento.
- LA, born and raised.
- Yeah, LA.
- I'm from the IE.
- That's a sad place to be.
So you could be a comic.
- I mean, at least you know.
- Where do you do stand-up at?
- Kind of everywhere, like,
private events, birthday parties.
- Birthday parties?
What kind of birthday
parties have you done?
- Friends, family, you know.
- Nichelle said she does birthday parties
and like, family events.
I've never let my family
watch me do comedy,
let alone round them up
and spew jokes at them.
You just do sets in front of family?
- Yeah.
- That's my worst nightmare.
- Well, my family is
full of, like, comedians
and crazy people, so.
- When do you take your light?
- Two minutes.
- Light?
- Whatever they tell me.
- The very first question,
when you want your light.
And she said, oh, just
whenever they give it to me.
I was like, that is not a thing.
- One.
- I'm same, I'm not picky about it.
- I'm a one minute guy.
- I'm headlining, I got a ten and a five.
I'm featuring or anything
less than that, a two.
- Okay. And I'm a one minute.
- Anybody do improv?
(all laughing)
- You do improv?
- I do, yeah. Improv,
sketch, I do stand up.
- All of it. Okay.
- When did you start doing comedy?
- Um, born this way.
I started doing it,
I guess last year.
Doing stand-up, but I've done it for
probably seven or eight years.
But standup, like last year.
(bell ringing)
(synth music)
- She's very nice. She's very smiley.
Which is generally a
red flag, I feel like.
- There's no way that
she's getting a lot of work
as a birthday comedian.
(elimination buzzer)
- Aw.
- [Ta'vi] You're gorgeous
though, girl. Stunning.
("Happy Birthday to You" playing)
- Isabella.
- Me?
- Yeah. Can you do one of your bits,
but can you do one with a tag?
Can you do a joke with a tag?
- A joke with a tag?
- How long you want her
to perform right now, bro?
- When Eric asked me what my tag was,
I, you know, I'm like live a little Eric.
Here, I'll, listen.
Okay. So I have this thing.
Don't worry. My back
actually, it goes really low.
So like my butt is really low on my ass.
So then I show, this
is a lot of how I end.
Is I show my back, see
how far that goes down
and you can't see one lick of crack.
So that's actually, that's
kind of my show stopper.
That's what I've been doing for a while.
- Okay, so it's like I don't have a crack.
You pull it down and what's your tag?
- It's I can't even do a
credit card swipe on this.
I have to do a chip insert.
And sometimes I say I got laughed out
of the Plumbers Association.
My sister would always tell me actually
that I had a back with a
hole in it, not to be vile.
And then I was like, is this normal?
How low my crack is on my ass?
Let me just see if this registers with,
you know, a wider audience.
- It's horrible.
'Cause my dad, he actually
got really mad at me last week
and he called me a (beep)
and I'm like, dad, that's messed up.
We don't call people (beep) anymore.
We call 'em millennials.
Yeah. Jubilee, boom.
There you go.
- Weed, I didn't smoke weed
until I came to California.
Cause I was in the military.
And like guys that smoke weed
when they found out that you haven't,
they talk to you about weed
the same way they talk to women about sex.
You wanna do it with
somebody like me, all right.
This stuff in my pants can
change your whole life.
Don't put the whole thing in at first.
- I gotta-
- Just put the tip in.
Don't interrupt my joke,
just put the tip in.
- I do, I do sketch and improv
but I've been playing a
baguette like a saxophone.
(jazz music)
And if you really sell that
you'd do that for like five minutes.
If you can get your whole mouth
on the baguette and just
start blowing on it.
It's, it works.
- I was watching Pinocchio the other day
and I was, Hey, this is just a movie
about a puppet that gets
more and more Jewish.
(booing)
- Let me give you the light right now.
- Last month I threw my
back out, trying to twerk.
I went to the chiropractor.
He said, Hey miss, how does that happen?
I said, well, you know,
I was popping that
(beep) for a real (beep).
He said, oh, your insurance
only covers fake (beep).
(Isabella laughs)
- I don't get it.
- I mean, there you go.
- Can everyone go around
and say their LPM.
- What does that mean?
- Is that like when I'm running
and I take my heart rate?
- Laughs per minute.
- Yeah. Laughs per minute.
- [Erik} All right
cool. See you guys knew.
- [Michael] I don't get laughs.
- Nobody talks about laughs per minute.
- It's not as much a thing
anymore, but I feel if you're
inside comedy, you've heard
it before, you know what's up.
If I say it
and it looks like you don't
know what I'm talking about,
you probably haven't been
in this game too long.
Hey, real quick.
How much is a, how much do
you get paid for a guest spot,
Usually?
- What the (beep)?
- People get paid?
- Zero dollars.
- Okay, you guys knew.
Just making sure.
(bell chiming)
(synth music)
- Tyler just seemed like there
was this fear in his eyes
that I was like, he's
never debased himself
the way that I have in front of people.
- I voted for him because he, nice guy,
he was bugging the (beep) out of me.
- Maybe that's his form of stand-up comedy
but that's not really what comes to mind
when you hear stand-up comic.
(elimination buzzer)
- That's all right.
(group clapping)
- Free yourself to baguette.
- I'm gonna look for that baguette.
- Have some bread.
- I shouldn't have said
the baguette thing.
Nobody really sees that coming.
- [Announcer] If you think
the mole is still in the box
and you'd like to
continue playing the game,
please raise your hand.
Okay.
Every time that you vote
someone out who is not the mole,
the prize money will be reduced.
- Okay. Thank you for telling
us that after we voted there.
- Yeah.
- You asked a good question
at the end about money.
You said you headline for now.
How much, how much you charge to headline?
- It varies, college and corporate
should be at least $1500.
If you're headlining a club
you should at least get between
$800 and $1200, if not more.
Feature sets get between,
on the low end $300,
we can maybe make $1000 at like
a good improv or something.
- Now are you guys really
suspicious of this man?
After the rounds we've been through?
Let's be honest here.
- You're right. You're right.
- Let's be honest here.
- We have three minutes,
let's make it real.
Who do you think is the mole?
- I'm torn, Isabella, James.
- Interesting.
- [Erik] You have a lot of
confidence coming off you.
And you say words that make sense.
- [Ta'vi] You could have
a friend who's a comedian.
- If anyone has had a lot of confidence
and has been fricking trying
to prove themselves, it's you.
Everything. You come off as
an entire fricking smörgåsbord
of info for every single simple question.
- But that makes me think
you guys are real comedians.
You're so desperate for
the approval of the group
that you're sort of laying
out your creds like that.
- Your bit, your bit was rehearsed.
Your bit was showing your butt,
so I'm a little skeptical of you.
- Or maybe you've just never
seen anything like it before.
And I'm sort of a revolutionary.
- [Erik] So she did like an act out,
and then she did a bit after it.
- Oh yeah, that is true.
I forgot about that.
- So she did do like
an actual set up punch.
Then she had like three tags.
- I low key think it's you.
- Me?
- Because we said professional
comedian, and are you?
- Define professional comedian.
- You would've had to
define it for yourself
when you applied to be on this show.
- I've gotten paid.
I do it every night.
I hit about three mics a night.
Yeah. I hit, I try to
hit like two open mics
at least every night.
You got to hustle to make it.
You know?
- Every time, when we ask you get paid,
he goes I don't ever get paid.
Ask about how long do
you ask for your light?
When we asked you for your light
you said I'll just do
whatever they give me.
- Yeah, because you show up to a show,
they say, oh, how many minutes you have.
It's either 5, 7, 10, or 12.
- I'm gonna be honest,
I could end this getting
out James and Isabella.
We could get out James and
Isabella and I'd be happy.
- Which one do you guys wanna do?
You wanna start a team?
- I think so. 'Cause I
feel like we're comedians.
- Wait, no one 'bout to
form alliance against us
when I'm a legitimate comic, yo.
(group exclaims and argues)
- Everyone had formed an alliance
against me, first of all.
Cause they're jealous.
How can someone be as good looking
and as quick on their feet as I am,
I know they, they just don't understand.
- And I was looking like, hold on now.
Don't try to rope me in as the mole.
I'm definitely not a mole.
Y'all shouldn't be making any alliances
that I'm not a part of.
- Isabella, right?
Come on.
- I guess I'm part of an alliance.
- I know myself.
- Are y'all voting for her
or me right now? Cause-
- We'll find out.
We will find out.
- I think it's gonna be me, but-
(bell chiming)
(synth music)
- I think that I voted for
Michael because of his shirt.
What did it say?
I survived an Italian mother.
- I thought she was given off
this vibe where it was like
I'm trying to act like a comedian.
She had really colorful clothes.
- Yeah, so that alliance was formed
and I stuck my fist in it.
I don't know if I was
invited, but I joined.
(elimination buzzer)
- I take my leave.
(group claps)
I understood.
People just don't get me.
- I can't believe you guys
would even suspect me.
Man, I cannot believe you guys.
- You got too much confidence.
- Me?
- Yeah.
- You still mad.
- Comics are sad.
You're too joyful.
- [Announcer] If you think
the mole is still in the box
and you want to continue playing the game,
please raise your hand.
Okay.
If the lights turn red,
that means the mole is still in the box
and you lose.
The lights turn green,
that means you voted the
mole out and you win.
(cheering and clapping)
Will the mole please step
out and reveal themselves.
(all cheering)
- We all have done a
ton of birthday parties.
That really is the most
common type of show.
- When you said family events,
I was like my family
does not like that I'm-
- Yeah. I mean, I talk
about being, I guess, jaded,
but it's, you know, it's
like, everybody's excited
to sort of show off what
they're passionate about.
It's very sweet.
- Well, my dad is a comedian.
He's a ventriloquist.
And then my older cousin,
he does comedy as well.
My whole family is just like so crazy
and full of like comedians
who are not professional
and then some real professionals.
- To really just have to
be in literally a box,
and it's like go.
I found that I still
possess that within myself
which is great
because I do not have any
other practical skills.
(group cheering)
(jazz music)